last week when we were taking live calls
on the Friday show I received a call
from someone asking me whether I thought
that new congresswoman Rasheeda thebe
was out of line for calling Trump a
mother effer and I mean I guess I should
say I'm saying mother effort because
we're on 200 broadcast radio and TV
stations and they can get fined if I
swear so I have to play along with the
FCC's rules it's not because I'm afraid
of saying what was said I just don't
want to get our broadcast stations in
trouble so Rasheeda Talib calls Trump a
mother effer
and the Wright goes crazy about decorum
and class and civility and tone and all
the stuff that they claim the left
actually goes nuts over this is what
Rasheeda Talib actually said in the
video all right take a look and when
your son looks at you says mama look you
won bullies don't win and I think that
baby they talked because we're gonna go
in there we're gonna impeach the mother
okay now I could play for you Sarah
Huckabee Sanders saying that the reason
she did this is because Trump's doing so
well that this is the only way they can
attack him I could play for you examples
of members of the Moral Majority Family
Values crowd saying this is
inappropriate I'm not gonna waste your
time with that because this is the
dumbest story of the year so far I don't
care about swearing I don't care about
insults calling him a mother effer
isn't offensive it's not an argument
either you can impeach him politically
or you can either impeachment is a good
strategy for Democrats or it's not a
good strategy for Democrats these are
the issues to figure out now as far as
the swearing goes it's total hypocrisy
for the right to pretend that this is
out of line when Trump has done it
countless times trumps on video talking
about grabbing women by the [ __ ] here's
Trump using the exact same terminology
in a political speech so we said well
why would you do what do you do so easy
I drop a 25% tax on China and you know I
said to somebody that is really the
messenger the messenger is importantly I
could have one man saying we protect you
25% and I can say another listen your
mother the room was cheering the same
people pretending that rafita the leave
is out of line were cheering when Trump
used the same word and yet here Donald
Trump saying that the new Congress
woman's comments were disgraceful and a
dishonor to her family Russia your
comment about the freshman
Congresspersons
comments specifically well I thought her
comments were disgraceful this is a
person that I don't know I assume she's
new I think she dishonored herself and I
think she dishonored her family could
not be more hypocritical I would
actually respect Trump for saying hey
you know what she used coarse language I
used the same language I don't care
about language that would be the
consistent position to take but instead
he says this meaningless stuff like she
dishonored her family like we're in
feudal Japan or something like that so
this is a bogus story the outrage is
pathetic their language policing pad
they are the ones that claim the left
police's tone and language they have no
legs to stand on because their guy is
just as crass as Rasheeda Talib yeah I
don't really don't care about this
language policing stuff I don't mind
that she used the word mf'er what I do
like though is that they're being fiery
that they're fighting back because
Democrats for the longest time we're
just too willing to play patty cakes and
compromise I think this new generation
is very good for the Democratic Party
and it's great to see well we'll see if
the sentiment about impeachment actually
does anything for them right that's
really the question not that she use the
term mf'er and you know the the other
thing that that's sort of being missed
here is that there are many valid
criticisms of Rasheeda Talib she's part
of a left that I don't really identify
with that she is part of Democratic
socialists of America I don't believe
socialism is
the path forward certainly not in the
next 15 years for improving our society
I think social democracy is the path
forward let's talk about that to leave
was a big player in the abolish ice
movement I think it's a non-starter for
Democrats at this time I think there are
way bigger fish to fry on the issue of
immigration
rather than abolish ice including daca
and many others Talib was she used to be
a supporter of a two-state solution in
the israeli-palestinian conflict now she
wants a one-state solution she's been
floating maps of literally Israel wiped
off the map with a Palestinian flag
where Israel is I think that's a
non-starter I don't think you're gonna
get any results or progress in the
israeli-palestinian conflict pushing for
a one-state solution she supports the
BDS movement I'm against that movement I
think that the success of the BDS
movement would damage the Palestinian
people in the West Bank who work for
Israeli companies so I think that
there's a bunch of stuff we could be
talking about here we could even look at
the identity angle that she pushes where
she says she's the first Palestinian
American member of Congress Justin a
MASH who's a Republican has a father
who's a Palestinian refugee so I don't
even know that she's right on the
identity game that she's playing the
last thing I would waste time
criticizing is that she said mother
effer
especially if you're Donald Trump so
there's plenty to look at here but she
swore give me a break
get out of your safe spaces stop being
triggered by adult language and go do
something that matters one of today's
sponsors is privacy calm slash Pakman
this is a free service that I've
actually been using myself for a while
now and I love it
you just take a few seconds to link your
debit card or bank account to privacy
coms mobile app or browser extension for
Firefox and Chrome and what that does is
allow you to instantly create virtual
credit cards that are linked to your
bank account so that you're not actually
putting your real debit card number on
the internet and you use these virtual
credit card numbers to buy things online
and with
click of a button you have the ability
to create multiple virtual cards delete
cards freeze and unfreeze cards you can
put a limit on a card so a company won't
be able to charge you more than you
actually want them to and it protects
you from being hacked it protects you
from companies being hacked which we've
been talking about for a while on the
program and it's perfect for signing up
for free trial somewhere if you don't
want your real credit card number to be
exposed and on file and their app and
browser extension let you autofill the
virtual credit card number into the
credit card field when you're buying
things online there are a ton of
different advantages to shopping and
paying bills with a system like this
everything is totally secure and
encrypted and in some situations you can
earn 5% cash back on your purchases it's
all completely free all you have to do
is click the link under this video to
get started and for a limited time
everybody in our audience who signs up
gets $5.00 towards your first purchase
when you sign up using that link below